[Aplausos]
en el año 1905 albert eisntein nos
presentó la teoría de la relatividad
hasta hoy parece que tenía razón
hasta hoy pero ese mismo año 1905 albert
eisntein también publicó algo que se
llama efecto fotovoltaico
a ese segundo parece que no le hemos
puesto atención
y tal
yo voy a tratar de explicar por qué
hay dos grandes temas en nuestra
civilización que nos están impactando
nos están impactando fuertemente el
primero nuestro crecimiento poblacional
como quizás instinto natural animal es
reproducirlos
lo que pasa es que nos hemos reproducido
demasiado rápido y demasiado rápido en
los últimos años la población humana ha
crecido en los últimos 100 años 350 por
ciento 7.7 billones de personas en el
planeta
claro no parece su ser una tendencia que
vamos a parar porque todos queremos
tener hijos quizás para postergar nos a
la historia la tirada es que cada
persona que nace o cada uno que vive en
el planeta requiere de energía
imagínense cuánta energía entonces hemos
requerido si la población sigue
creciendo
ese tema es vital pero además no parece
ser que vaya a cambiar de rumbo esa
curva va a seguir ascendente
aceleradamente tenemos el segundo tema
de segundo tema es el crecimiento
económico todos queremos vivir mejor
mañana que ayer
todos
el problema es que un país desarrollado
consume 10 veces más energía que un país
subdesarrollado entonces conforme todos
queremos vivir mejor
vamos necesariamente tener que consumir
más energía y el crecimiento económico
que hemos tenido como civilización en
los últimos 100 años es del 2000 por
ciento
es una esencia quiere decir que ahora
todos queremos un cambio todos queremos
abrir condicionado que todos queremos
nevera todos queremos obviamente más
energía y es que la energía la ocupamos
para todo aquí hoy
yo a mí yo ya tengo hambre y eso
nosotros cosas más que mi cuerpo
pidiendo energía
el carro las luces del teléfono en
nuestro mundo está hecho de energía y
eso tal vez nos ha costado un poco
entenderlo entonces qué sucede cuando
combinamos esos dos factores crecimiento
de la población radicalmente vertical
con un crecimiento económico que ambos
requieren energía pues lo que hay que
terminado sucediendo es que en esos
mismos 100 años la demanda energética de
nuestro planeta ha crecido 1000 por
ciento
en 100 años tres generaciones
o sea que en los últimos tres
generaciones de nuestros abuelos a hoy
nuestro planeta requiere mil por ciento
más de energía
es preocupante
algunos a eso le llamamos yaoi cambio
climático huella de carbono capa de
ozono como lo queramos ver pero la
verdad la verdad es preocupante porque
ambas tendencias el querer vivir mejor y
que seamos una mayor población no son
tendencias que van a parar entonces
tratemos de no utilizar los plásticos y
tratemos de no contaminar y tratemos de
no usar los muslos en los carros pero
esas dos tendencias van a seguir y la
necesidad energética va a continuar
y lo peor es que toda esa necesidad
energética la estamos sacando del único
lugar que tenemos el planeta
el planeta
en las formas que lo queramos ver carbón
gas natural petróleo madera aire viento
en el ríos
sólo tenemos uno como que se nos olvidó
que solo tenemos un planeta que creímos
que podemos hacer con lo que quisiéramos
y seguir aquí creciendo y malgastando lo
porque eso es lo que hasta ahora hemos
hecho malgasta en nuestro planeta
y sólo tenemos 1
qué responsables
bueno pero hasta aquí esto no es nuevo
esto ya lo estamos oyendo ya ustedes lo
sabían muy probable no me hubieran
invitado en la noche a esta charla si no
trajera una mejor noticia que eso
hay una mejor noticia que eso ese efecto
fotovoltaico de don albert einstein de
hace 113 años
ese efecto fotovoltaico lo que hace es
tomar una energía que no es del planeta
por primera vez logramos entonces tener
una energía que podemos utilizar que es
inagotable porque es fusión pero que no
está aquí de nuestra estrella
increíble y ahí lo hemos tenido
preciosos amaneceres tienen para que
atardeceres y si se ponen a pensar en
realidad toda esta energía que estamos
carcomiendo nos del planeta provino de
ahí para empezar cuando sabían limo de
las cavernas y quemamos un poco de
madera para hacer una fogata aprendimos
el fuego ese árbol existió porque tuvo
fotosíntesis porque venía del sol y no
importa que nos hayamos comido hoy sin
el sol no no los hubiéramos comido
fuente primaria de nuestra energía es el
sol y ha sido siempre el sol
con el efecto fotovoltaico logramos
simplemente tomarlo directo y no del
planeta
y porque hoy sí podemos hablar del sol
pública entonces no hace 113 años
empezamos a resolver el tema y lo
tomamos de ella bueno porque
tecnológicamente no era accesible y
vieran que este cuento tampoco se los
hubiera dicho hace sólo cinco años hace
diez años esto no era ni soñarlo
hace sólo cuatro años la energía solar
incursión en nuestra sociedad
radicalmente y eso es simplemente porque
en addis 1977 un watt solar costaba 77
dólares pero el 2013 costaba 77 centavos
de dólar
así de dramática fue la caída que hemos
tenido en los paneles solares y vieron
que desde el 2013 hoy a la mitad
entonces la caída tan exponencial que
estamos logrando en los paneles solares
o la tecnología que toma la energía del
sol y no las da ha hecho que ya hoy y
esto es cuestión no solo los últimos dos
años la energía solar es la energía más
barata que conocemos
ya no tenemos otra ya le ganamos al
petróleo ya le ganamos a la nuclear ya
le ganamos al viento ya le ganamos a la
hidro darles una idea que en costa rica
muy particularmente alguien que pone
paneles solares recuperó su inversión en
5 años pero la vida útil del panel es de
25 años entonces tiene 20 años de
energía gratis sí gratis porque lo único
que hay que hacer es lavar el panel
entonces será que hemos encontrado
energía gratis
y si no totalmente gratis muy cerca de
ser gratis
guau increíble para ponérselos en
perspectiva si en eeuu pusiéramos 100
millas por 100 millas llámese 10 mil
millas cuadradas en paneles solares
le damos electricidad todos eeuu con
solo esos paneles solares le podemos dar
toda la electricidad a eeuu con la
tecnología actual esto en el futuro esto
ya hoy se puede hacer
pero tenemos un problema
el sol solo lo tenemos en el día
suena como fácil pero ese es el problema
el problema entonces es como hacemos
porque no lo tenemos todo el tiempo
bueno es que nos hemos acostumbrado a
utilizar energía acumulada con otras
palabras baterías
qué es un embalse de agua el arenal
reventazón es una batería
qué es el sándwich que nos comemos es
energía acumulada en un sándwich pero
entonces el carbón el petróleo el gas
natural todos los recursos naturales que
el planeta nos ha dado en esencia es una
batería que se llenó de energía durante
millones de años solo que en los últimos
100 años hemos decidido malgastar y
tiene un límite se acaba entonces hemos
estado utilizando toda la energía que se
acumula del planeta por millones de años
no los estamos comiendo en tres
generaciones tenemos un problema
si vemos la evolución del ser humano
cuando descubrimos el fuego se nos
transformó todo o sea no solo salimos de
la caverna es que pudimos ver de noche
podemos cocinar y nos convertimos en el
animal más inteligente después
descubrimos claro el carbón y empezamos
a utilizar máquinas con mucha fuerza
después encontramos el gas natural pero
en qué simpático cada vez que
encontrábamos una fuente de energía
nueva más barata más accesible la
civilización creció y entre más energía
hemos encontrado más accesible más crece
la civilización entonces pareciera que
como civilización si descubrimos una
nueva fuente de energía vamos a lograr
mucho vamos a volver a crecer si a esos
paneles solares de eeuu le ponemos una
batería de una milla por una milla ya le
podríamos dar electricidad a eeuu toda
la noche con tecnología actual eso ya es
posible eso no es el futuro
solución entonces es tomemos la energía
barata del sol y almacenamos la
estoy seguro que ninguno de ustedes
salió de la casa esta mañana se encargar
el celular todos ustedes ya tienen un
mecanismo de almacenaje no nos están
vendiendo vehículos eléctricos no se
están vendiendo baterías con llantas
ya nos estamos acostumbrando a acumular
energía nos urge nos urge aprender a
acumular energía pronto rápido
y porque yo creo en los cambios en
cuestión de 13 años
el carro desplazó por completo al
caballo el caballo tenía 500 años de
existir y vino el carro y en cuestión de
13 años lo cambio se imagina en nuestro
mundo sin carlos los últimos 100 años
dramática transformación pero la
logramos la podemos hacer y tomo 13 años
tiene sus consecuencias digamos que si
adoptamos esa energía gratis y digamos
que si la guardamos como ya lo estamos
haciendo qué hacemos con infraestructura
vieja
cuando yo crecí el que tuviera un pozo
de petróleo tenía el futuro asegurado
pareciera que ahora el pozo de persona
no tiene el futuro asegurado
porque apareció la competencia y mucho
mejor
increíble como les suene pero entre los
países que más paneles instalaron el año
pasado qatar y arabia saudí
simpático el que ha tenido el petróleo
pero pensamos por instante en positivo y
cuáles serían las consecuencias de tener
esta energía solar y poderla almacenar
la primera es que democratizamos la
energía y qué quiere decir eso pues que
hasta ahora el mundo ha peleado hemos
tenido guerras nos hemos agarrado en
toda nuestra historia por el recurso
quien ha tenido el petróleo domina manda
y los que no lo tienen pues salados
porque quien tuviera energía dominaba a
los demás
en la energía solar sale en el norte o
en el sur por igual alumbró el pobre o
el rico por igual se imagina la
transformación en nuestro planeta
geopolítica si efectivamente emigramos
hacia una energía gratis y que si
podemos almacenar
imagínense por un instante que un vuelo
de europa costará nada porque la energía
gratis
se imaginan lo que sé de eso transforma
el mundo pero lo mismo podríamos decir
para la comida la ropa el aire
acondicionado este hotel cuánto costaría
lékué la habitación en este hotel si la
energía no costará nada el salto
cuántico que está a punto de dar nuestra
civilización gracias al efecto
fotovoltaico es alarmante encontramos ya
otra fuente de energía y es que ya la
tenemos solo que hace cinco años no la
teníamos acabamos de celebrar la misión
del apolo y que llegó a la luna sí pero
cuando el apolo aterrizó en la luna le
quedaban 15 segundos de combustible
se imaginan ahora si volviéramos otra
vez a la luna y allá en la luna
apuntamos a nuestra estrella y volvemos
a llenar los tanques es que el problema
ha sido y por qué no vamos a otros
planetas de por qué no podemos llevar
tanto combustible el problema es como
llevamos de energía bueno es que ya
descubrimos que no hay que llevarla la
energía está en nuestra estrella no en
el planeta nos estamos equivocando tanto
en seguir usando nuestro planeta
tenemos que evolucionar tenemos que
seguir viendo en positivo se puede lo
podemos lograr tenemos que entender que
hay mejores formas de hacerlo pero
tenemos que hacerlo rápido porque no
tenemos el tiempo y sobre todo el efecto
que está causando la demanda energética
hay un astrofísico ruso nikoláy gorda lo
que en 1964
básicamente se atrevió a clasificar las
civilizaciones hizo todo un análisis de
un profundo y como se clasificó la
civilización y cogió y dijo que una
civilización que depende de los recursos
del planeta en que vive se le conoce
como una civilización planetaria
pero que conforme la civilización crece
madura aprende se vuelve más inteligente
y aprende a usar su estrella y no su
planeta donde vive se le conoce como una
civilización estelar
y aquella civilización que aprende a
utilizar múltiples estrellas porque
todas son de fusión de energía
inagotable se le conoce como una
civilización galáctica
pues en esencia si vemos nuestra
evolución empecemos con el fuego fuimos
evolucionando sí pero ya va siendo hora
que dejemos de ser una civilización
planetaria va siendo hora que aprendamos
que tenemos que dejar de dañar nuestro
planeta y que hagamos uso de la fuente
que siempre nos dado energía el sol
estamos ya hoy con toda la posibilidad
de lograr convertirnos en una
civilización estelar
hagamos nuestros telares muchas gracias
[Aplausos]